the movie air is opening today and we
realize that Michael Jordan wore two
numbers in his career 45 and 23 and the
date is 4 5 23.
I read the script and I was like blown
away I was like this is all true Did you
you have a meeting with Michael or do
you make Ben do that I made Ben do that
yes first of all we said look look we're
not going to do if you don't want us to
do it we're not going to do it and he
was like no no it's a good idea for a
movie Ben said what's most important
that we get right and what he spoke
about were three things there was Howard
white who's an executive that Chris
Tucker plays in the movie uh George
rattling who Marlon Wayans plays and
then he talked at length about his
mother so when Ben said like look who do
you think we should get to play before
he finished the question Michael was
like Biola Davis yeah so so he called me
he was like I got great news and bad
news and I'm like okay and he's like the
great news is I know exactly what to do
for the rewrite like we got you know
we're going to put in George Bradley
we're putting Howard white and we're
going to make his mom Central to the
whole thing and I go look great what's
the bad news because we have to get
Viola Davis